you guys are here to start your central
intelligence training these instructors
are really intense because military guys
right it is a push-up that was a little
rough could be a chance for Team Johnson
the show that we have what it takes to
win you guys are about to be the rock
bottom okay you know what moving too
fast bottom line are you in or you out
all right guys listen up you're about to
get you first ace to the field lost the
satellite encryption codes guarded by
bad guys starting at your base camp
you're going to recover the code and
bring it back to your safe zone your one
team run the mission and the next team
will have a chance to feed their time
worried about you team Johnson we've got
the heart and that's what it's going to
take to survive in this competition it's
all fun and games until we're out there
and then it's serious business pretty
follow me let's do it no what's up I
doing here oh you you go you big behind
you last words for team all right
they're going down team Johnson is all
talk team heart is all action go okay
we're gonna go this way
I'll come your man
from I was trying to keep the strategy
and the tactics and all the techniques
that we learn in mind while still moving
forward I've got one right over here
I was freaking out just got difficult
when I first saw the briefcase it was so
out in the open and I thought like as
soon as we step in there everybody's
just getting lit up I am I going after I
found that I was the only one protecting
Evan so I feel macho wide open right now
I got my ninja skills really held at the
end when I just saw an opening and I ran
to the finish line
how they looking we're gonna go this way
go move up team one it's gonna go left
team twos can I go right let's get the
case ready go hey I got all of a sudden
I heard fire next thing I know oh sorry
Russ for shooting you in the neck
multiple times it's pretty fun clear it
I was pretty sure one of us was going to
be able to grab it and get out of there
because I didn't see any of the other
team around his government I thought I
was gonna get rained out by a bunch of
bullets and I was prepared for that
didn't happen I got it you guys got to
clear the bus kmart was taking a nap
they were not where they needed to be
good
my team performed phenomenally we
defeated team high we beat them by at
least a minute 30 seconds we're gonna
take that and go into the final round
and we're gonna win look out team heart
we're gonna squish you like a bug we
kind of got our butts kicked but this
next time we're gonna come together with
real gonna knock it soon do I have any
words for team Johnson let that do the
talking
final mission team heart against team
Johnson head-to-head round I am
definitely more nervous in the world of
international espionage things aren't
always what they seem
you